The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
hello and welcome.
As I mentioned last
time, we're essentially
done with the course.
We've done all the
theoretical underpinnings.
What remains is to talk about
two important applications
of Fourier, in fact
some applications that
are very difficult to do if we
didn't have Fourier analysis
and in fact quite
simple to think about
once we have Fourier analysis.
So today I'm going to
talk about sampling.
We'll spend this lecture and
the next lecture on sampling.
And then the following two
lectures will be on modulation
and we're done.
So we're almost done.
So we've talk about
sampling lots in the past.
In fact, it was on the
very first homework.
That's in fact I think
one of the strong points
of this course is that we
regard continuous time signals
and discrete time
signals on equal footing.
And part of the goal is to be
very comfortable to convert
back and forth, because
both representations are
so important.
We see CT coming up
in fundamental ways,
because a lot of the things
that we're interested in
are systems based on physics,
and that's just the way it is.
Physics works in continuous
time by and large.
However, because of
digital electronics,
we like to process things
with digital electronics,
because it's so inexpensive.
So for that reason, we
want to go back and forth.
And what we'll see
today is that when
we think about system
levels, when we think about
signal level conversion,
Fourier transform is the key.
So keep in mind
we've already thought
about how you would convert
a CT system into a DT
representation.
We did that back in
about Homework 3 or so.
So what's special today
is thinking about--
rather than thinking
about systems,
thinking about signals.
And as you can imagine,
there's enormous reasons
why you would want to
think about signals
from a digital point of view.
Virtually all the things that
you play with all the time
are digital.
So you think about
audio signals,
they're now stored digitally.
Thing about pictures, digital.
Video, digital.
Everything on the web, because
there's no other way the web
can work.
If it's on the
web, it's digital.
So there's just
an enormous reason
why we would like to understand
how to take a continuous time
signal and turn it into a
discrete representation.
This is just motivation.
We tend to think
about common signals
that we deal with
everyday as though they
were in continuous time,
continuous space, same thing.
We think about
things like pictures
as though they were continuous.
They aren't.
Anybody who has a
digital camera knows
that if you zoom in enough,
you see individual pixels.
They are not continuous
representations.
They're discrete
Even some kinds of
pictures that are ancient--
well, ancient by your
standards at least.
Even well-known kinds of
pictures like newsprint,
in an underlying sense, they
are discrete representations.
So what's showed
here is a picture
of a rose and a halftone
image of the type
that would be printed
in a newspaper.
And if you zoom in,
you can see this--
so if you zoom into
this square so you
can see this better, this,
which is not really continuous,
I'm showing it on a
digital projector,
it's actually got pixels too.
But the pixels are small
enough for the time being
I'm going to ignore that.
So consider this continuous
even though it isn't.
And you can see the discrete
nature of this one much more
clearly.
In fact, the halftone
pictures that you
see in a newspaper are not
only discrete in space,
but they're discrete
in amplitude,
because they're
printed with ink.
Ink comes in two
flavors, ink or no ink.
So they are a binary
representation in intensity
as well.
And we'll talk about that a
little bit more the next time.
So in order to have a complete
digital representation,
you need to think about not only
sampling in the time or here
the space dimension,
but also sampling
in the voltage or the
amplitude dimension.
Even the highest resolution
picture you have ever seen
is digital.
So this refers to the
completely ancient technology of
how do you make a digital print?
So a very high-quality
picture is
made from an emulsion of some
sort of a chemical, originally
silver bromide.
The idea was that you
had very small crystals
of silver bromide that
could be reduced by a photon
to turn them into silver metal.
And the idea was that
exposure to light
would therefore convert
silver bromide to silver.
And then developing meant
washing away the silver bromide
salt that remained
that was not converted,
leaving behind the
silver that had.
And that was the basis
for the chemical reaction
that gave rise to pictures.
The point being that even
there, these crystals
are on the order of
a micron in size,
and they're either on or off.
So even there it was
a sampled version.
And if it weren't enough,
everything you've ever seen
is sampled, because that's
the way your eye works.
Your eye has individual cells
that either respond to light
or don't.
There's about 100 million
rods, about 6 million cones.
So every image you have
ever seen is sampled.
So one question is--
and it's such a good sampling
that you don't even notice.
But maybe that's because you're,
well, unaware, to be polite.
So think about, how
well sampled is it?
So I know that this picture is
sampled, because I can come up
and I can see the
individual pixels.
I can see a little
grid of pixels.
There's 1,024 by 768.
I want you to think about how
well your eye is sampling that
by thinking about
whether or not you should
be able to see the
pixels from where
you're sitting based on the
sampling that's in your retina.
So look at your
neighbor, say hi.
Figure out whether you have
enough rods and cones to see
individual pixels or not.
OK.
Does anybody-- so who can tell
me a way to think about this?
Or who can tell me the answer?
Do you have enough rods and
cones to sample the pixels
on the screen?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: No.
DENNIS FREEMAN: No.
AUDIENCE: I can't see them.
DENNIS FREEMAN: You
can't-- you cannot.
AUDIENCE: I don't
see the pixels.
DENNIS FREEMAN: OK.
Well, that could be
because you don't
have enough rods and cones.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have
slight astigmatism.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Ah.
Astigmatism.
Is that a rod and cone problem?
AUDIENCE: That's a lens problem.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
That's a lens problem.
So maybe you have enough rods
and cones and not enough lens.
There's actually another reason
you might not be able to do it,
besides rods, cones, and lenses.
AUDIENCE: Your brain.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Brain.
There's even another one.
OK.
We're up to-- there's
another reason why
you might not be able to do it.
Rods, cones, lenses, brains.
AUDIENCE: Photons.
AUDIENCE: Photons?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Photons.
That's an interesting thought.
I think you could probably
pull that off, yeah.
The number of photons-- if
the lighting were low enough--
your eyes are very sensitive.
You can see-- you can see--
you can report a difference
with one photon, one.
It's pretty little.
It's kind of the limit, ? right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's so far away
that I can't see the pixels.
DENNIS FREEMAN: It's so far away
that you can't see the pixels.
But why?
Is it because you don't
have enough rods and cones,
because your lenses
are screwed up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So you might
be using your rods and cones
for different things.
Your cones are focused in an
area called the fovea, right?
So one way you could improve
that would be to look at it.
Can somebody think of something
besides rods, cones, lenses,
and brains?
Can somebody think of
convolution lecture
with some sort of application
that we did in convolution?
No, of course not.
That was more than
10 lectures ago.
In convolution, we looked at
the Hubble Space Telescope
and we looked at a microscope.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There's going to be
tons of particles in the air,
so--
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Particles in the air.
That was something that
happened in Hubble.
So smoke-filled
rooms, that's bad.
From the Hubble experiment,
from the Hubble lecture
we talked about how there
was a point spread function
associated with diffraction.
And there's also a
diffraction limit because
of the size of your pupil.
Because you're looking
through a narrow aperture,
that limits the
resolution as well.
But let's get back to
this, rods and cones.
You have enough rods and cones.
How you do that?
How do you think about whether
you have enough rods and cones?
OK.
Step 1, look at
the previous slide.
What was the important
thing on the previous slide?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Three microns
per rod and cone, right?
So rods and cones are
separated by three microns.
So what do I do with that?
How do I compare rods and
cones three microns to this?
Anybody remember
anything about optics?
So I have this big lens, right?
And we have the eye on
one side and we have
the object on the other side.
And we need to map
some retina over here
to some screen over here.
What's important to do--
what's the important thing
to do in the map?
Oh, come on.
Do you all remember
going to high school?
No.
OK.
So if you have a lens, rays
go straight through a lens
without being bent, right?
That's one of the
rules for lenses.
So that is enough information
actually to tell us the map.
The map through a lens is
so as to preserve angles.
So if we figure out
how closely spaced
are the rods and
cones on this side,
that'll give me some
angle that I can resolve.
And the question is
whether that angle
is bigger or smaller
than the angle that's
required to resolve the pixels.
So the angle-- so if we make
a small angle approximation,
say that theta is on
the order of sine theta,
then the spacing between these
is like three micrometers.
The distance between the lens
in your eye and the retina
is on the order of, say,
three centimeters, something
like that.
So that's the angle at your eye.
And the question is,
how does that compare
to the angle at the screen?
And so the screen, this
is like three meters.
But the pixels, there's
1,024 pixels in that range.
And this distance is like 10
meters, something like that.
So the question
is whether or not
the angle subtended
by the pixels
is bigger or smaller
than the angle subtended
by the rods and cones, right?
That's the issue.
And so if you work
that out, the angle
between the rods and cones
is on the order of 10
to the minus 4 radian.
And the angle between
pixels is on the order
of three times that.
So a couple of
interesting things.
You have enough rods and cones
to see it, but only barely,
by a factor of three, roughly.
I'm not worrying
about the fovea.
The fovea has more.
So this is just a
crude approximation.
I'm not worried about
your eyeglasses.
But crudely speaking, you
have enough rods and cones
to resolve the pixels and
another factor of three or so,
which means, for example, that
making a projector with three
by three times more
pixels makes sense.
And making one that's got 100
times 100 times more pixels
doesn't.
And that's the
kind of thing we'd
like to work out
when we're thinking
about discrete
representations for signals.
How many samples do you need?
OK.
So what we'd like to
do today is figure out
how sampling affects
the information that's
contained in a signal.
We'd like to sample a signal--
so think about the
blue signal here
and think about the red samples.
We'd like to sample
a signal in a way
that we preserve all of the
information about that signal.
And as you can see from
the example that I picked,
it's not at all clear
that you can do that.
In fact, if you look
at the bottom picture,
I have coerced two signals to
follow on the same samples.
So the green signal is
the cos 7 pi n over 3
and the red signal is
the cos pi n over 3.
And they all go through
the same blue samples.
The same blue samples is shared
by both of those signals.
So it's patently obvious that
I cannot uniquely reconstruct
a signal from the samples.
That's absolutely clear.
It's also clear by just thinking
about the basic mathematics
of signals.
A CT signal could move
up and down arbitrarily
between two samples.
How could you possibly
learn information
about what happened
between the samples
by looking just at the samples?
So it's not at all
clear that you're
going to be able to do this.
So let's take the opposite
tact, which is to say,
let's assume I only
have the samples.
What can I tell you about what
the signal might have been?
What's the relationship between
the samples and the signal?
And the way to
think about that--
one way is to think about
something that we will
call impulse reconstruction.
If I only had the
samples, what could I
do to reproduce a CT signal?
The simplest thing I
might conceive of doing
is replace every sample
with some non-zero component
of the CT representation.
So I only have
samples up here at nT,
so generate a new CT
signal that contains
the information in the
samples, that is to say x of n,
which means I only
have an integer
number of non-zero elements
in the CT representation.
So in order to make that signal
have a non-zero integral,
the things I represent
each sample with better
be an impulse,
otherwise I would have
finitely many non-zero points
in a finite time interval,
and the integral
over the interval
would be 0 always, right?
So I have to use impulses.
So the simplest thing
I could do would
be to take every
one of these samples
and replace it by an impulse
located at the right time,
so put the n-th one at
time t equals n cap T,
put it where the
sample came from,
and scale the weight
to be in proportion
to the amplitude of x of n.
That's kind of the simplest
thing I could possibly do.
That's called impulse
reconstruction.
And then lets ask
the question, how
does the x that I started with
relate to this xP, this impulse
reconstruction thing
that I just made?
And as you might imagine
from the theory of lectures,
that relationship is
going to be simple, right?
So think about, what am I doing?
I'm trying to think about
I started with x of n--
I started with x of T, sorry.
I turned that into samples.
I turned that into xP of t.
And now I'm trying to
compare those two signals.
That's the game plan.
So think about x of P
from the previous slide.
It's weighted impulses
shifted in time
to the appropriate place.
This x of n was derived by
uniform sampling of x of t,
so x of n was x of nT.
And since this impulse is
0 everywhere except where
the argument is 0,
it doesn't matter
whether I call this thing
nT or T, same thing,
because the impulse only
looks at t equals nT.
So whether I call it
nT or t is irrelevant.
If I call it t, then
this part has no n in it
and I can factor it outside and
I just get an impulse train.
And not too surprisingly,
xP is just the product--
this signal is just this signal
multiplied by an impulse train.
So if I derive xP by
multiplying by an impulse train,
your knee-jerk
reaction is to say--
multiply by an impulse train?
AUDIENCE: Sounds like
a Fourier transform.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Sounds like a
Fourier transform somewhere.
If I multiply in time
by an impulse train,
what do I do in
Fourier transform land?
Convolve, right?
Multiply in time,
convolve in frequency.
So if this was my
original x, this thing,
if this is the
transform of that thing,
and if this is the transform
of my impulse train--
transform of an
impulse train in time
is an impulse
train in frequency.
The impulses in frequency
are separated by omega
s equal to 2 pi over t.
And the amplitude is equal
to omega s, 2 pi over t.
So there's space and have an
amplitude, both the spacing
and the amplitude are
2 pi over t, right?
And if I'm multiplying
in time x times P,
I convolve in frequency.
So this is my answer.
What's the relationship
between x and xP?
It's multiplied in time
by an impulse train,
or it's convolved in frequency
with an impulse train.
So the answer how
does xP relate to x,
it looks very similar
for some frequencies.
But there's a lot
more frequencies.
Not too surprising.
I multiply by impulses.
Impulses have all
frequencies, right?
So what I've done
when I've sampled it,
if I think about the sampled
signal being represented
in CT as the multiplication
by an infinite impulse train,
I've introduced new
frequency components
to the Fourier representation.
That's the main message.
This slide is today's lecture.
The way we can think
about sampling in time
is as convolution in frequency.
OK.
So let's think about
that a little more.
What I just talked about
was the relationship
between the Fourier
transforms of x and xP.
But the goal is to
think about the samples.
So what's the relationship
between the DT, the Discrete
Time Fourier transform
of the sampled signal,
and the continuous time Fourier
transform of this impulse
reconstruction?
So I've already for you--
I've compared the frequency--
the Fourier representations
of these two.
As an exercise, you compare
the frequency representations
of those two.
And figure out if any of
these are the right way
to look at it.
So look at your neighbor.
So which one best
describes the relationship
between those Fourier
representations?
Number 1, 2, 3, or
none of the above?
OK.
So 100%, I think.
So easier question, is
x of e to the j omega--
x of e to the j omega, so this
one, x of e to the j omega,
is that a periodic or
aperiodic function of omega?
AUDIENCE: Periodic.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Periodic.
What's the period?
What's the period of
x of e to the j omega?
What's the period
of e to the j omega?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So I'm hearing
about the three not quite
correct answers.
They all kind of have
the right stuff in them.
What's the period
of e to the j omega?
What's the period of cosine?
AUDIENCE: 2 pi.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 2 pi.
Thank you.
OK.
So this one's periodic in 2
pi, so x of e to the j omega
is periodic in 2 pi
because e to the j omega
is periodic in 2 pi, right?
How about xP of j omega?
Is that periodic or aperiodic?
xP of j omega.
xP is the signal that I got when
I multiplied in the time domain
x of t times p of t, p of
t being an impulse train.
Take an impulse train times
the time domain signal,
and that's how I got xP.
And then xP is the
transform of that.
Is the transform of xP
periodic or aperiodic?
AUDIENCE: Periodic.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Periodic.
What's a period of xP?
AUDIENCE: 2 pi over T.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 2
pi over T precisely.
So this one is
periodic in omega.
2 pi-- I shouldn't
write it that way,
I should say that
the period is 2 pi.
And here, the period of
omega is 2 pi over T.
So what's the relationship
between omega and omega?
In order to make a function--
in order to make a
function that is similar,
we're going to have to
have omega is omega over T.
OK?
We're going to have to
convert the units of capital
omega, which are radians, into
the units of little omega,
which is radians per second.
So we need a time in the bottom.
And if you want to be a little
bit more formal about it,
you can just write
out the definitions.
I did this last time.
This was from two lectures ago.
So here's the definition
of the discrete time
Fourier transform, right?
You take the samples
and weight them
by e to the minus j omega n.
Here's the definition of
the CT Fourier transform,
where I've substituted
xP of t is this thing.
It's a string of impulses,
each weighted by x of n.
And then I interchanged the
integral and the summation.
And I don't worry about whether
it's going to work or not.
You have to take a following
course, Course 18, in order
to figure out whether that
makes sense or not, but it does.
So I interchange the order and
then the end part factors out
and this just sifts out
the value of omega--
the value of t and nT.
So I replace then
this t with nT.
The integral goes away.
And I end up with something that
looks almost exactly like that,
except that capital
omega has turned
into a little omega times T.
So the discrete time
Fourier transform
is just a scaled in
frequency version
of this impulse-sampled
original signal.
So the impulse reconstruction
is related to the Fourier--
the Fourier transform of
the impulse reconstruction
is related to the Fourier
transform in samples
by scaling frequencies that way.
So those representations
have the same information
precisely, except for
the scaling of frequency.
The period in the
bottom waveform is 2 pi.
The period in this one
is 2 pi over capital T.
So the answer to the
question then is easy.
The original question
was, under what
conditions can I
sample in a way that
preserves the information
in the original signal?
Well, this diagram makes
it relatively clear.
If the original x was just
one of these triangles
and xP is the periodic
extension of that, then so long
as the periodic extensions
don't overlap with each other,
I can derive x from xP by
simply low-pass filtering.
Throw away the
frequencies that got
introduced by the convolution
with an impulse train.
So as long as the
frequencies don't overlap,
as long as there's a clean
spot here where there's nothing
happening, as long
as the frequencies
of the periodic
extensions don't overlap,
then I can sample in
a way that contains
all of the information
of the original,
so long as when I'm all
done, I low-pass filter.
That's called the
sampling theorem.
So the sampling theorem,
which is not at all obvious
if you don't think about
the Fourier space--
if you only started with the
time domain representations
that I showed in the
first few slides,
it's not at all
obvious that there even
is a way to sample in an
information-preserving fashion.
But what we've just
seen is that it's
really simple to think about
it in the Fourier domain.
Thinking about it in the
Fourier domain gives rise
to what we call the
sampling theorem, which
says that if a signal
is bandlimited--
that has to do with
this overlap part--
if the signal is
bandlimited that
means that all of the
non-zero frequency elements
are in some band of frequencies,
nothing outside that band.
Outside some band, I don't
care what the band is,
but outside that band, the
Fourier transform has to be 0.
If the Fourier transform
is 0 outside some band,
then it's possible to
sample in a way that
preserves all the information
so long as I sample fast enough.
So if the original signal is
bandlimited so that the Fourier
transform is 0 for frequencies
above some frequency omega m,
then x is uniquely
determined by its samples.
Uniquely means that
I can do an inverse.
So it's uniquely
determined by the samples
if and only if omega s,
this is sampling frequency,
which is 2 pi over t--
that's the period of
the impulse train.
So if 2 pi over t exceeds
twice the frequency of the band
limit.
We'll see in a minute where
the factor of 2 comes from.
The factor of 2 comes
from negative frequencies.
So the sampling
theorem says that there
is a way for a certain
kind of signal.
Signals that are
bandlimited can be
sampled in a way that
preserves all the information.
So here is a summary.
If you sample uniformly-- that's
not the only kind of sampling
we do in practice, but it's the
basis of all of our theories
for the way sampling works, so
that's the only one we're do
in 003.
But just for your
intellectual edification,
there are more sophisticated
ways to sample.
And in fact, that's a
topic of current research.
But for the time
being, we're only
going to worry about
uniform sampling.
If you sample a signal
uniformly in time,
that is every capital
T seconds, then you
can do bandlimited
reconstruction,
which means that replace every
sample with an impulse weighted
by the sample weight
and spaced in time
where it would have come from.
Then run it through an
ideal low-pass filter
to get rid of the stuff
that high frequency copies.
And what comes out
will be equal to that,
as long as you've satisfied
this relationship,
that the frequencies that
are contained in the signal
must be less than the
sampling frequency over 2.
OK.
So what's the implication
of the sampling theorem?
Think about a
particular problem.
We can hear sounds with
frequency components that range
from 20 hertz to 20 kilohertz.
What's the minimum-- what's
the biggest sampling interval T
that we can use to retain all
of the information in a signal
that we can hear?
So what's the answer?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6?
OK.
A sort of shrinking
number of votes and sort
of a shrinking number
of correct votes.
So it's about 75%.
The only tricky part really
is thinking about frequencies.
So I told you frequencies in
the commonly used engineering
terms--
I told you that we
hear frequencies
from 20 to 20,000 hertz.
In this course, we usually
think about frequencies
as omega radian frequency.
Hertz are cycles per second.
There's 2 pi radians--
hertz are cycles per second.
Radian frequency is cycles
per second radians per second.
There's 2 pi radians per cycle.
OK.
Sorry.
I screwed that up.
Hertz is cycles per second.
Omega is radians per second.
The conversion is 2
pi radians per cycle.
So we need to have--
the highest frequency
in the signal
has to be smaller than the
sampling frequency divided
by 2.
The highest frequency
in the signal
is 2 pi fm, if f is
frequencies 20 to 20 kilohertz.
And the sampling frequency
is 2 pi over capital T.
So you clear the
fraction and figure out
that T has to be smaller
than 25 microseconds.
OK.
So the idea then is
that there's a way
of thinking about any signal
with a finite bandwidth--
there's a way of
sampling using uniform
sampling so that you can
sample that signal without loss
of information.
All you need to do is
figure out how frequently
you need to sample it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Implications?
A signal is not badlimited.
DENNIS FREEMAN: If a
signal is not bandlimited,
you have a problem.
AUDIENCE: Is it
possible to [INAUDIBLE]?
DENNIS FREEMAN: So the
question is, to what extent--
is it possible to sample a
signal that is not bandlimited?
So that's the next topic.
So the question I'm
going to address now
is, well, what happens if you
don't satisfy the sampling
theorem?
What if there are frequency
components that are
outside the admissible band--
the admissible region
of frequencies?
So to think about
that, I'm going
to think about this as
a model of sampling.
So I think about--
and the value of the model
is that it's entirely in CT.
It gets confusing
when you mix domains
and you have to compare
this kind of a frequency
to that kind of frequency.
So what I'm going to do is
think about it entirely in CT
by making a model of
how sampling works.
Sampling is equivalent to take
the original signal that you're
trying to sample, multiply by
an impulse train showed here.
You get out this xP thing
that we've been talking about.
And then run that through
an ideal low-pass filter.
And if this comes out
looking like that,
then the sampling preserves
all of the information.
Now what I want to do
is think about what
happens when I put in a signal
for which that doesn't hold.
So let's start with the
simplest possible case.
Let's think about
a tone, so a signal
that contains a single
frequency components.
So I'm representing that by a
cosine wave, cosine omega o T.
So I'm representing that by
two impulses, Euler's equation.
And I'm thinking about some
sampling waveform, where
I'm looking at it here in
frequency, so the spacing is
2 pi over T. And if the
frequencies in the signal
are smaller than 1/2 of
the maximum frequency omega
s, everything should work.
And you can sort of
see in the Fourier
picture what's happening.
When I convolve
these two signals--
I multiply in time, so I'm
convolving in frequency.
When I convolve this
with the impulse train,
this impulse brings this
pair of frequencies here.
But this impulse brings
this pair up here.
And then this one brings
So I repeat.
So I get a repetition
then of the original two
at integer multiples of omega s.
OK.
So if I low-pass filter
then with the red line,
everything's fine.
I end up with a signal
with the output that's
the same single as
the input, no problem.
What happens, however,
as I increase frequency?
Same thing.
The originals are
reproduced here.
The modulation by this
brings this up to here.
The low-pass filter
still separates it out.
The problem is here.
Now I'm running into trouble,
because the original signal
fell right on the edge of
my limit, omega s over 2.
And the problem's
even more clear
if I go to an even
higher frequency.
So now, this component
is coming out here,
which is outside the box.
The thing that's
happening, though,
is that convolution
with this guy
is bringing in an element
that is spaced by omega s
and is now inside the box.
That's bad.
Everybody see what's happening?
So I'm just studying what
happens as I have one frequency
and vary the
frequency-- if I have
a tone at a single
frequency and I
vary the frequency
of the tone, as long
as the frequency is inside
my limit, omega s over 2,
I'm fine.
The low-pass filter
reconstructs the original.
But something bizarre
happens whenever I'm outside.
And to see what's going
on, it's easiest to see
what's going on by making
a map between the input
frequency and the
apparent frequency,
the apparent frequency
of the output.
So what happens if I'm
at a low frequency,
I'm on a linear relationship
between the input
frequency and the output.
The output reproduces
the input exactly.
And you can see as I'm
increasing the frequency,
I'm just sampling this
function at a different place.
But when I go higher, it
appears as though the frequency
got smaller.
We call that aliasing.
This is a question to get you
to think through aliasing.
But in the interest of
time, because I have a demo,
I'll leave this for
you to think about.
So the question is,
thinking about what's
the effect of aliasing and
where do the new frequencies
land relative to the
input frequency--
they have this funny
folding property.
And the effect of the folding
property kind of wreaks havoc.
So I'll skip this for now
and just jump to the idea
that the intuition
that we get by thinking
about single frequencies carries
over to complex frequency
representations.
So now what if my message, what
if my input had this triangular
frequency Fourier
transform, rather than
just a single spike?
And so I'm sampling
it as showed here,
so this is my impulse
train and frequency.
And as before, the message gets
reproduced at integer multiples
of omega s.
And as long as the bandwidth
of the message is small enough,
I can put the red
low-pass filter
to eliminate the copies
from the periodic extension,
and I get an output
that's equal to the input.
The problem is
that if I increase
the bandwidth of the
input, as I increase
input, the margin
between the base signal
and the periodic extension
gets smaller.
And if the bandwidth gets too
great, they begin to overlap.
So now if I low-pass
filter this signal,
I pick up the desired
blue part of this,
but the undesired
green part of that.
And the result is
that the signal is not
a faithful reproduction
of what I started with.
Same sort of thing happens if
I hold the message constant
and change the
frequency spacing.
As long as I sample with
big enough frequencies--
that is small enough times.
There's an inverse relationship
between frequency and time.
If the frequency is big enough
so the times are short enough,
I can reproduce what
the signal looked like.
But now if I change the
sampling to happen slower,
I start to get aliasing.
So it's exactly analogous.
So that means that if
you have a fixed signal,
there's some minimum
rate at which you
have to sample it in order
to not lose information.
So what I want to do
now is demonstrate that
by thinking about music.
So I have a cut of music that
was originally taken from a CD,
so it was sampled
at 44.1 kilohertz.
That's standard CD
frequency sampling.
And I've re-sampled it
at 1/2, 1/4, 1/8, 1/16.
And I'm going to play
what happens when I
do these various re-samplings.
[MUSIC PLAYING - JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH, "SONATA NO.
1"]
[MUSIC PLAYING - JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH, "SONATA NO.
1"]
[MUSIC PLAYING - JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH, "SONATA NO.
1"]
[MUSIC PLAYING - JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH, "SONATA NO.
1"]
[MUSIC PLAYING - JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH, "SONATA NO.
1"]
OK.
Some you may have been able
to tell the difference.
So the idea is
that by decreasing
the rate at which I'm
sampling it in time,
I get fewer samples in the total
signal, which makes it easier
to store and increases
the amount of stuff
that I could put
on a given medium.
That's good.
Problem is, it
doesn't sound as good.
So every step down this
path resulted in 1/2
the information of
the previous one,
which means that I could
double the capacity
of your MP3 player.
But there was distortions
added because of this aliasing
problem, because some of
the frequencies at the lower
sampling rates were too large
to be faithfully reproduced
by the sampling.
They got moved, they got
aliased to the wrong place.
That gives rise to sounds
that are inharmonic
and they sound bad.
So this just recapitulates what
we were seeing in the demo.
I started out barely having
enough bandwidth to represent
the original signal.
And as I made the sampling
frequency smaller,
making the distance
between samples bigger--
as I made the frequency
of the sampling smaller,
I started to get overlap, and
that's what sounded funny.
So the slower I sampled, the
more overlap and the funnier
it sounded.
So the question
is, what can you--
how can you deal with that?
One way you can deal with that
is what we call anti-aliasing.
So it's very bad if you put
a frequency into a sampling
system where the frequency
is too big to be faithfully
reproduced, because it comes out
at a different frequency that
cannot be determined
from the output alone.
So how can you deal with that?
One way you can deal
with it is to pre-filter,
take out everything that could
be offensive before you sample.
That's called anti-aliasing.
And the result is not faithful
reproduction of the original.
But it's at least
faithful reproduction
of the part of the band
that is reproduced.
So it's not distortion-free.
The transformation from the
very input to the very output
is not--
there's not a unity
transformation,
because you violated
the sampling theorem.
But at least you don't alias
frequencies to the wrong place.
So the result t--
I'll play without anti-aliasing,
with anti-aliasing, without,
with, without, with.
[MUSIC PLAYING - JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH, "SONATA NO.
1"]
OK.
So the final one didn't sound
exactly like the original,
but at least it wasn't grating.
So the idea, then, is just
that sampling's very important.
And by thinking about it
in the Fourier domain,
we get a lot of insights that we
wouldn't have gotten otherwise.
See you tomorrow.